hello everybody and welcome to today's
webinar on PubMed tools and work
identifiers for authors my name is Peter
Cooper and I'm going to be monitoring
the question spot during webinar Marie
Collins is going to be presenting during
the webinar if you have a question
please put in the question spot I will
try to address simple questions during
the while Marie is talking if there are
more more complicated ones or one that
ones that I think everybody should hear
the answer to all I'll read them to
Marie at the end and she will answer
them and if there any we don't get to or
ones that we don't know the answers to
I'll make available a question and
answers document that will be available
and those are going to be linked to our
webinars in courses page there is a
directory that as Marie's slides on our
FTP site there's a Godot usa.gov URL
there in the bottom of this slide and I
will send that out and chat everybody so
with that I'm going to go ahead and turn
it over to Marie Collins who is part of
the PubMed team here at NCBI hi and
welcome to the NCBI minute today I'm
going to be talking about author
disambiguation and the search strategies
and tools in PubMed that will help you
create a comprehensive and precise list
of publications for an author whether
that author is you yourself or someone
else we're also going to talk about let
me get to my agenda slide we're also
going to talk about the advantage of
registering for and working ID which is
a unique author identifier that you can
submit with your publications to PubMed
or including your bibliography or CD
beyond that we'll talk about additional
tools that have been created to help you
manage your own bibliography this gives
you the control to tweak and customize
your citation list then decide if you
want to share it or assign a delegate to
assist with managing it so when I talk
about ambigú a ssin or a disambiguation
in pubmed there's really two flavors of
ambiguous author names there's the case
and we see this a lot in PubMed where we
have a single author who has published
under many names and if the author has
gotten married or changed their surname
for any reason this adds a layer of
complexity
the basic rule of thumb in PubMed is to
always search with the last name and
initials the three names you see here
Smith Smith Jones and Jones are three
unique last names in PubMed so for
complete retrieval for this authors
citations you should use or to combine
the various names that the author has
published with the second flavor of
ambiguity comes from a single name that
could belong to many different authors
in PubMed as we saw earlier the best way
to search is for last name and initials
and in this case I'm searching for young
M and I'm getting more than 4,000
results the fastest way to narrow this
down is to add the middle initial if I
know it another option would be to add a
topic since I'm looking for the Nobel
prize-winning scientists who studied
circadian clocks I could add that term
here but since I know the author's
middle name I'll add the W and this will
really target my search another way to
confirm that this is the author you're
looking for beyond adding the middle
initial or narrowing your search with
subject terms is to look at the
affiliation data I have additional
evidence that this is the MW young I'm
looking for he's affiliated with the
genetics lab at the Rockefeller
University
we've been including the affiliation
data for all authors in PubMed since
October of 2013 and in December of 2014
we began accepting multiple affiliations
for authors and these data really help
us identify whether or not we found the
author that we are actually looking for
if I click on the author name from the
abstract view the 138 citations in my
results list will be sorted by computed
author which weighs important citation
information like subject terms
co-authors and affiliations and clusters
the citations in the order that they are
most likely from the same person we
think this algorithm is very successful
since we do see that users find what
they're looking for on the first page or
two
results when they sort this way I'm not
published in PubMed so I can't do this
using my own name but if you are an
author searching for your own citations
in PubMed obviously it would be very
easy for you to choose a starting point
view the citation and abstract view and
click on your name and you'll see the
sort by author label above your result
of course we know that some of these
retrieval methods may include citations
that are not yours
or leave out some that are especially if
you've changed your name
we accept unique identifiers in PubMed
the publisher can submit this number
with the citation data publishers can
also update existing records and add
your identifier retrospectively to your
citations in PubMed and this unique
author identifier is part of that sort
by author algorithm that we just saw so
in addition to co-authors affiliation
data subject terms and your name we're
also adding in the orkut ID and that
helps obviously with the accuracy of
that sort by author orchid if you're not
familiar stands for open researcher and
contributor identification it is a
persistent identifier and an industry
standard that can be applied not just to
scholarly publishing but extends to
other areas of research and sharing such
as data blogs software code and much
more it has become a broadly accepted
mechanism for identifying and crediting
ownership of output of research but its
continued success depends on the
collaboration between researchers
publishers universities granting
agencies and other stakeholders in
scholarly communication and I think that
MLM falls solidly in that last category
as a stakeholder we are encouraging all
researchers to register for an orchid ID
which they submit with their
publications and other research output
we've integrated orchid with our science
CD platform which aids in the creation
of the nih biosketch used in the grant
management process the advantage of an
orchid ID is that it's a persistent
identifier unlike a name which
not unique and could change over time
you can search in PubMed just by
entering the orchid ID number you don't
need to add a field tag to that because
PubMed is really good at sensing that
that's what what you're looking for is
that orchid ID based on the pattern of
that number in addition to the author
sort additional affiliation information
and the inclusion of orchid IDs my
bibliography is a powerful tool that
helps you save and share your citations
you can sign in to my NCBI with your
existing Google NIH or ER a Commons
account if you click on the link there
that says see more third-party sign-in
options you'll see that that includes
many universities and you can use your
existing credentials to register for my
NCBI as well or you can create an
independent account just for NCBI the
process is intuitive but you can always
contact the support center if you run
into trouble this is the my NCBI home
page just to set some context if you've
never looked at it before and you can
customize this page add remove and
reorganize these portals on the home
page you can think of each of these as
windows and into an existing NCBI
resource you can create and share your
bibliography even if you're not applying
for grants or managing grant reporting
however much of the design and the
features of my bib really came about in
parallel with the NIH public access
compliance needs it helps with reporting
the progress of scientific research
there are four ways to build your
bibliography and I'll go over those now
from within PubMed the process is simple
you simply execute an author search
select some citations and then use the
send to menu to send them and the
citations to your bibliography then you
click on save you'll get an explicit
confirmation and you'll be returned to
PubMed because that's where you started
but there's a link at the top and the
bottom that says edit your bibliography
and that would bring you right back to
your my bib page to edit your
bibliography if you want to
citations while you're in your my NCBI
account click on my NCBI to get started
this link appears at the top of all
PubMed pages and then you click on
manage my bibliography they are in the
my bib portal you'll see the three
options next to your bibliography if you
don't have any journal articles they
won't appear I've been playing with this
for years adding citations that aren't
my own to my bibliography so you can see
that this is already populated and then
I have the three options for adding
citations if you click on add from
PubMed you'll see a search box and you
can go ahead and execute your search
from within my bib on this screen you
can Sulton see that I can select
citations to add and it shows the
citations that are already part of your
bibliography so if you see anything with
a grayed out check mark and then gray
text you can tell pretty easily that
those are already in your bibliography
and not an option for adding okay so to
get to this screen again we're starting
by clicking my NCBI then manage my
bibliography and then from that menu
that you saw before at this time you
would select add manually to get this
form that you can fill in there's a pick
list at the top and right now we've
selected books and chapters which is not
something that traditionally appears in
PubMed so you wouldn't have a PubMed
citation necessarily to import the other
options on that list include Journal
article that does not appear in PubMed
meeting abstracts presentations patents
data set or database software and I
think there are a couple others if you
select upload a file you'll use your
browser's file management system to
navigate and upload any MEDLINE or
bibliography citation files so here you
can see the two options that are
available are a MEDLINE file and then an
n-bit which is a bibliography citation
format so now you have a bibliography
and you can change the settings to make
it public or private you can share the
URL if the collection is public you can
edit settings if you look at where that
letter B
you can edit settings and I'll go into
that part in a little bit more detail
where you see the letter C you can
modify your display settings you can see
right now it says ListView sort by date
group by citation type there are other
options that you can explore there you
can look at these actions that are
available and they're all very intuitive
you can move citations from your
bibliography to another collection and a
bibliography is just a special
collection within my NCBI that has been
named for you but it behaves like any
other collection that you may have
created you can move citations you can
delete citations copy them and view you
can also suggest this is the one feature
that you might not have anticipated or
be familiar with you can actually check
next to a citation you could suggest for
example to a co-author that they add it
to their bibliography as well and when
you send that suggestion through email
they have a chance to review it and
either accept or refuse that suggestion
and then I put this letter e here just
so you'll look and see how many links
are available there this is a
bibliography but it still has a lot of
the links you see in your results set in
PubMed you can link to the pubmed
citation if you click on the title or if
the full text is available it will tell
you and you can link out to the full
text or free full text and then you can
also find related citations and I
encourage you to explore this page it's
very intuitive but there is extensive
online help for my bibliography now I'm
going to go ahead and we'll we'll look
at what I see if I click on edit
settings because my bibliography is
public you can see I set it to public
there I will see a direct URL and the
HTML that I could add to webpages and
blogs if my bibliography was set to
private those options would not be
available for sharing but that is how
you share your bibliography you can
either email that URL to people or they
have the HTML there for embedding it in
a webpage or blog you can assign
delegates as well and
you do this through the account settings
page and you can see here that you can
link at the bottom of your my
bibliography settings but this is
actually the same as if I clicked on my
username at the top of the page that
would take me to my settings and that's
where I could assign a delegate now if I
go to my NCBI settings you can see that
delegates option I can add a delegate it
just is a matter of adding the person's
email and then selecting the service
that I want them to be a delegate for
whether it's just my bibliography or my
bibliography and sciencv and sciencv is
a tool that we use to take all of this
bibliographic information sort of helps
in the processing and exporting then of
that data into an nih biosketch or other
formats other types of biosketches that
are available today i talked about
working IDs and my bibliography in the
context of author disambiguation and
tools for identifying collecting and
sharing your citations these tools are
also a very powerful part of the grant
application and compliance process very
quickly I want to show that my bib has
even more features if you've logged in
with your er a Commons account or have
linked the two accounts this really
helps track citations and manage the
compliance progress if you're not
familiar with era Commons it's an online
interface where grant applicants
grantees and federal staff at NIH and
grantor agencies can access and share
administrative information relating to
research grants and so if you look at
this page you can see here that there's
actually different symbols whether it's
an exclamation point or the yellow that
will tell you the status of these
citations in terms of the NIH funding
process so today in this NCBI minute I
mentioned a lot of tools and processes
but didn't cover them in depth and here
are some links to additional short
webinars that you can watch and I listed
these in order of their relevance to
today's presentation I think if you do
nothing else and you're involved in the
grant management process
it would be really helpful to spend the
17 minutes watching the first two videos
and if you want to discover other ways
that my NCBI brings more power to really
a lot of the NCBI database experience
watch the previous NCBI minute
recordings that are listed here on
tailoring your PubMed search experience
and automating searches and saving
collections and the online help for my
NCBI is very comprehensive and truly is
helpful if you if you get stuck or
you're not really sure what all your
options are on all of these screens I
added the link to the online help there
and if anyone has any questions that
weren't answered thanks Marie actually
there are a lot of questions that
weren't answered because I don't know
that much about this particular topic to
be honest with you so I'm going to go
through them and hopefully you can help
answer them there's sort of a mixed bag
of things many people are asking sort of
general questions about my NCBI and my
bibliography by the way if we don't know
the answers to these questions
we'll find them out and get them in that
document so the first one is if you
change institutions and your my NCBI
account is through that institution how
do you retain your data so I've never
tried to do that but I will tell you
that you absolutely can because that
happens all the time and working both in
education and on the help desk
I would absolutely be aware if that was
a thing that you could not do so um I'll
get the answer and I'll put it in that
document that Peters gonna include with
the materials in terms of the exact
steps for transferring everything if
you're affiliated with one institution
you may have you may have addressed this
I was too busy looking at the questions
pod so forgive me if this is you already
answered this can individual authors
edit their past records to include work
it IDs so if by record you mean your
pubmed citation no authors cannot
publishers can and honestly if you reach
out to a publisher and either they are
no longer it has to be the publisher
who's the active data provider for that
journal and that's another thing that
switches a lot is data that refer a
journal that was once submitted by
high-wire next year might be submitted
by Elsevier or a Silver Chair or some
other third-party vendor
so we always ask that you reach out to
the publisher they have a very very
user-friendly system they can use to
come in and edit any of the citation
data that they provide or that they're
allowed to provide for PubMed they can't
edit mesh terms obviously but if the
publisher was to write back and say I
can't do that we could certainly do that
for you it's a couple that are sort of
general my NCBI questions one is how do
we get our institution added to the
third-party lists for login options so I
think the best course for that would be
to email info at NCBI NLM NIH gov I
think info at is probably the best
helpdesk that would be able to route
that request through get it to the my
NCBI developers and you know work work
on adding that to the list okay so can
you share part of a bibliography instead
of everything honestly the way I would
do that a bibliography is just by
default a collection called my
bibliography you could create another
collection that's called Joe Smith's
bibliography and have that be a subset
of your complete bibliography and share
that and and I think that's the way I
would do it is make one or the other
either the my bibliography could be the
subset or but I would tend to keep that
as the superset because you can import
citations from your bibliography right
into sciencv so you could create other
collections that are just sort of the
subsets of your complete bibliography
call it anything that you want and those
collections act the same way as a
bibliography and you would be able to
access the URL and share it I think you
probably did address this but where does
one go to start to create a work at ID
so I might run through my slides just so
that I'm not wrong I think it's just up
working org honestly but let me get
there yeah it's just orchid dot word
takes about 30 seconds it might have
been faster for me because I don't
actually have any publications to link
but but creating the orchid ID itself
takes about 30 seconds and it's free
okay is there an option to transfer
bibliography to the EndNote or others
of where I should know this but I'm not
gonna lie but I can get the answer to
that question on the way to do that but
yeah I mean if you've got any list of
any citations in PubMed you can easily
export them to an end bib file even if
it's a question of looking at those
results looking at that collection in
PubMed and just using the sendto from
there but if there's an easier way I'll
add it in Peters document so we have a
couple people asking about the slides
the compressed length ago usa.gov link
that I sent out does work one
possibility for some of you is that
that's not an FTP site so it's possible
that that's not accessible to your
computer for some reason I'm going to
send the uncompressed you FTP URL you
can try changing the first part of the
address instead of FTP to HTTPS and see
if that helps
one question that somebody asked was if
you have a publicly ography is that
searchable by Google
okay and the other question is is pub
Ed's author clustering algorithm
publicly available I'm not sure if that
one is we typically put them into the
online help so if you go to help in
PubMed and then you search for sort by
author or author typically we do include
those algorithms whether it's that one
or similar articles or relevance you
know it is in the help if it's not I'll
check and see if I can track that down
okay we have I think we have time for
one more question this one is maybe
something that you would mentioned in
passing during the webinar I'm not sure
can you demo sending suggestion to a
co-author to add a site to their
bibliography sure all right this way
you'll see how I sign into NCBI if this
okay so now I'm signed in as me and I
will go to my NCBI and I'll go to my
bibliography and I go to manage my
bibliography and then there's a
suggestion
oops I need to select something first so
I think that this I have a co-author
here and literally you put their name
and you put their email and if I decide
to send it to myself literally send the
suggestion but that's as simple as it is
okay I think that's all we have time for
there are some unanswered questions in
the question spot and so I'll be sure to
get those into a document
okay thanks Bree and thanks everybody
for coming I'm going to go ahead and end
the webinar now
you